>> Greg: A PLANE CRASHED IN
TURKEY, TEXAS.
APPARENTLY THE PILOT WAS FLYING
IN A LOW ALTITUDE IN ORDER TO
DROP THE ORANGE AND 50 GALLONS
OF PINK WATER WHEN IT SLAMMED
INTO THE GROUND.
THE REASON FOR THE PINK WATER,
AND A OF YOUR PARTY.
THANKFULLY NOBODY DIED, MINOR
INJURIES BUT CAN'T SAY THE SAME
FOR A WOMAN WHO WAS KILLED BY AN
EXPLOSION THAT WAS PART OF
ANOTHER GENDER REVEALED.
I SAW YOU YONG, EMILY.
[LAUGHTER]
IBAN PHRASES THAT BECOME
REPETITIOUS AT THE END OF THE
DAY.
GUESS WHAT, JUAN?
THE NEED TO BELONG LEADS US TO
ADOPT WHAT WE SEE IN OTHER
PEOPLE AS A WAY NOT TO STAND
OUT.
FITTING IN KEEPS YOU FROM
GETTING KILLED.
UNTIL IT KILLS YOU.
TODAY, MOST IDIOTIC BEHAVIOR
SEEMS TO GET THE MOST ATTENTION.
WE SEE MORE PEOPLE DOING DUMB
THINGS SUBCONSCIOUSLY TO BELONG
AND KNOWINGLY TO BE NOTED.
IT BECOMES A VIRUS.
WE SAW THIS WHIZ KIDS AND TIDE
PODS BUT ADULTS AREN'T MUCH
BETTER AND THE MEDIA DOESN'T
HELP BY SPREADING DUMB TRENDS
FAR AND WIDE AND ALL YOU'RE LEFT
WITH IS A GIANT MESS THAT OTHER
PEOPLE HAVE TO CLEAN UP.
POP A BALLOON FILLED WITH PINK
OR GLUE GLITTER OR AS THE DOCTOR
THAT GENDER AND KEEP IT TO
YOURSELF.
NO ONE CARES!
IS ENGENDER A SOCIAL CONSTRUCT
ANYWAY?
WHO IS TO SAY IT'S A BOY OR A
GIRL, AND YEARS FROM NOW IT'LL
BE AGAINST THE LAW ANYWAY.
SOCIAL MEDIA MAKES EVERYBODY
DUMBER.
>> Juan: WHEN YOU SAID VIRUS,
I THOUGHT THAT'S THE KEY WORD.
THE REASON THE PEOPLE DO THIS
KEY STUFF IS SO THEY CAN PUT IT
ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND IMPRESS
THEIR FRIENDS.
I GUESS THIS WAS A VERY RICH
STUPID PERSON BECAUSE THEY HIRED
AN AIRPLANE.
GRADE: 350 GALLONS, EMILY.
PINK WATER BECAUSE I GUESS IT'S
A GIRL, I'M ASSUMING, I DON'T
WANT TO GET ANY LETTERS.
A PINK GIRL.
>> Emily: PINK WATER IS
DISGUSTING.
EVERYBODY HAS A PROBLEM -- IT'S
JUST ENOUGH TO TELL YOUR FRIENDS
AND FAMILY AND HAVE A CAKE OR
WHATEVER.
EVERYTHING HAS TO BE OUTDONE FOR
THEIR PERSONAL, NARCISSISTIC
REASONS OF HAVING TO GET A TON
OF LIKES.
REMEMBER THE ERRORS IN A FIRE
LAST YEAR?
40,000 ACRES AND $8 MILLION
BECAUSE SOMEBODY WANTED TO TELL
THE WORLD --
>> Greg: THAT WAS CAUSED BY A
GENDER REVEALED PARTY.
SHOULDN'T THESE PEOPLE BE SUED?
WHOEVER HAS TO DO WITH THIS
MESS?
>> Dana: AS THE FARMER FROM
THE FIELD?
I'M NOT MUCH FOR EXTRA
LITIGATION.
I DID I THINK THAT'S NECESSARY.
BUT I'M GLAD PEOPLE ARE EXCITED
ABOUT THEIR KIDS.
I THINK THAT'S AN EXCITING
THING.
>> Jesse: IS IT REALLY?
>> Dana: I THINK IF I WOULD
EVER HAD A BABY, I WOULD LIKE TO
THINK I WOULD WAITED TO BE
SURPRISED AT THE BIRTH.
I THINK THAT'S GOD'S GIFT TO
YOU.
SURPRISE!
>> Greg: I GET
>> Greg: I GUESS SO
JESSE, YOU HAVEN'T REVEALED YOUR
GENDER YET.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: YOU ARE ALL WRONG ON
THIS.
I AM PRO GENDER REVEALED FOR A
FEW REASONS.
FINDING OUT THE GENDER OF YOUR
BABY IS PROBABLY THE MOST
THRILLING MOMENT OF SOMEONE'S
LIFE.
IT'S UP THERE.
AND HAVING THAT -- CONSEQUENTIAL
TOO.
BEING ABLE TO SHARE THAT WITH
OTHER PEOPLE IS REALLY FUN AND
EXCITING.
I HAVE NEVER BEEN TO A GENDER
REVEALED PARTY BUT IF SOMEBODY
INVITED ME TO ONE, I WOULD BE
THERE EARLY.
I WOULDN'T NEED TO KNOW THESE
PEOPLE.
I WOULD GO TO A STRANGER'S
GENDER REVEALED PARTY JUST TO
BE, LIKE, IT'S A GIRL!
ALSO, GREG, YOU ARE FORGETTING
ABOUT THE COMEDY CONSEQUENCES.
DO NOT DEPRIVE US OF COMEDY.
MANY BLOOPERS COME FROM GENDER
REVEALS GONE WRONG.
THE GUYS LOOKING AT A BASEBALL
FIELD PINK OR BLUE, MRS. COMMITS
HIMSELF IN THE HEAD, FALLS IN
THE POOL?
WHEN I'M ONLINE, THERE'S ONLY A
FEW THINGS TO DO.
THERE IS FAKE NEWS AND